no no
43 ese es el número de los hijos
sobrinos y hermanos desaparecidos hace
seis años en la china para en la víspera
del sexto aniversario de la masacre de
los normalistas familiares y amigos se
exigieron justicia en un caso que aún no
brinda respuestas claras sobre el
paradero de los 43 estudiantes
desaparecidos el 26 de septiembre de
2014 fueron detenidos en la ciudad de
iguala por las autoridades y
presuntamente entregados a un grupo
criminal llamado guerreros unidos que al
parecer quemó los cuerpos y los arrojó
en un basurero de la localidad de cocula
algunos expertos han rechazado esta
versión y aseguran que las pruebas
fueron manipuladas durante la
presidencia de enrique peña nieto
de extensiones concretamente a todos los
responsables
materiales como los que llevaron a cabo
en la investigación
tras la llegada de andrés manuel lópez
obrador al poder en 2018 se cree una
comisión de la verdad con los familiares
de los desaparecidos y la fiscalía
mexicana luego del hallazgo y la
identificación de una de las víctimas en
el mes de julio el encargado de la nueva
investigación prometió sin seriedad
por dolorosa que ésta sea pero no os la
inventan una nueva una historia y vamos
a generar las fuerzas expectativas de
estimular
y la oficina del alto comisionado de las
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos en méxico reconoció los logros
alcanzados de la nueva comisión y alentó
al estado a intensificar sus esfuerzos
para esclarecer el caso y el paradero de
las víctimas